i love this man's work and his new show
is dynamite he is a an executive
producer and director of severance which
is available now on apple tv apple tv
plus new episodes releasing every friday
starring friend of the program adam
scott how about this rest of this cast
in part john turturro patricia arquette
and christopher walken joining us here
on the rich isaac show is ben stiller
how are you doing ben
hey rich how's it going i'm doing well
thanks i'm thrilled to to have you uh
here on this program uh before you
joined us i i read out my uh my residual
checks um my foreign royalty statement
from sag after um what what is the the
longest ago check you receive uh for any
uh small amount of money five cents or
anything like that which is what is that
for you oh wow
um i go way back rich i've been around
for a while yeah so
um i'd say maybe even like kate and ally
nelly episode
what were you doing who were you and
kate and ali back in the day i was if um
i was a like a young she was like when
kate or ali i forget who went back to
school
you know like you know as an adult and i
was in her class at a community college
and i was a student activist and we were
protesting something that was going on
right that's all i remember i remember
that it was at the ed sullivan theater
that's where they taped episodes which
was really exciting really and yeah and
i still yeah every once in a while like
a you know like a ten ten dollar eight
dollar check comes in for that for kate
and ali so that was that a very special
episode of kate nelly
uh i don't think it was like no it was a
sort of non not it's not special episode
run of the miller
1986. okay you played a character named
peter peter too late the rebel was the
name of the department there you go
gary that's right check your mailbox now
you know maybe like oh yeah and also
maybe uh i did miami vice too back
around that time and that comes in every
once in a while miami vice did you did
you last the episode or were you um i
was i was one scene i was uh an
informant who worked at a
religious good store and
crockett came in to ask me some
information brian dennehy was the main
guest star he was the real guest star
and i just had a scene
oh
in a religious store huh is that what
you're saying amen send money
wow
that was uh that was um
very exciting because i got to go down
from new york and you know that was a
big job to get for an actor back then
you know to get it to get a spot on on
miami by my god so i guess in a way you
know if this was like a kevin bacon
thing i've done many csi miami's i've
done some of those i played you know i
played uh reporter
um and uh and then also myself i did
that once so did you did you say i i
only caught the end of it but you said
draft day are you in draft i am andres
then this is an amazing story okay i'm
in draft day yes i'm in draft day and uh
we recorded um my scene if you will um
at radio city music hall on the friday
of the three day draft and they shot me
doing my normal nfl network draft
uh night material on thursday and asked
me to wear the same clothes for friday
for continuity purposes as you know
right um and so
because i had my day job or my night job
with the nfl network or the draft i mean
it's it's it's a bear of an assignment
so i didn't really look at my scene i
figured you know what i'll just wing the
lines and then
it's time to do the scene and it's with
frank langella like the real deal like a
real
dude a real actor and he comes i mean
like i can't even i mean that's an
understatement to call him that and he
comes up to me and says do you want to
run through our lines
and i panicked
because i had no idea what my lines were
and i
panicked like i've in a way like like i
didn't do
not since the third grade when i didn't
do my homework you know like it
literally was a panic moment for me but
it was it was a
amazing so i have been in a scene with
frank langella
yeah i mean frank langella is a great
actor and intimidating to most very
seasoned actors too so to be jumping in
with him and not knowing your lines is
like a like a bad dream that i would
have you know because i literally do
have dreams like the
sort of cliche actors nightmare dreams
of not knowing my lines or not you know
not being prepared for something but
that's that's like literally that would
be scary so uh ben stiller here apple tv
pluses severance he's the director and
executive producer of the show and we'll
get to that in a second so what is it
like to be hooked up to a uh
a truth uh a lie detector with robert de
niro asking the questions what is that
like oh man
you know that whole experience was sort
of felt like you know every day being in
that sort of like under the you know his
eye and like sort of i think he made it
for because he's a method actor he
didn't make it easy for me he wanted me
to always feel uncomfortable
um he really did feel like that the
whole time and uh you know and and and
bob because now i do call him bob
um you know
he's such a sweet guy but like he really
understood what the dynamic was there
and you never know because he could be
like he would really you know every once
while he would laugh at something and
then every once in a while he'd get
really really mad about something and
you never knew which way it was going to
go and of course when you get angry it's
like the de niro that we all you know
fear you know the good fellas
so uh it was very fun i didn't have to
act at all it just sort of
existed in that movie i love that i mean
i got to be honest with you i've uh on a
i've seen that movie so many different
times and in so many different places
i've seen it on a plane and at 35 000
feet i've never been on a plane where
every person it was on one of those old
school planes where everyone was
watching the same thing i've never heard
a plane laugh hysterically
quite like that film and that scene in
particular and i thought so was that ad
lived in any way or were those lines
actually
nailed i mean it was all you know we we
worked on the script and and you know
at that time every day we would come in
and like maybe like make little tweaks
and you know bob would try stuff but i
don't remember like doing like a lot of
improvising except you know it's the
kind of thing like you just you throw
something every once in a while but the
improv kind of comes sometimes when
you're working with the writer and the
director to kind of figure out stuff and
that jay roach directed the movie he's
like great tom directed to austin powers
and you know he he was awesome at being
able to get people to like play around
and have fun um but also you know you
knew what you did going in you weren't
like having to make it up at the time
i love it i love it and then um
do you have a good brett favre story
from back in the day
ben stiller you got a good fire story
for me i mean i remember no i don't
really have
i remember you know
that that actually
in was an improv in that movie where i
don't quite know how to pronounce his
name
far over or whatever that was because i
i literally didn't understand how to
pronounce his name
i still don't know because
it's funny we had the family brothers on
the first year of this show eight years
ago and they told us that you did have
trouble pronouncing his name so that is
true like that was totally true yeah
yeah yeah uh but every day on that movie
was like an adventure because you know
the fairleads would have so much fun
making a movie
at first you're like what is going on
here because they really didn't take it
seriously um you know but cut to like 20
years later p fairly wins best picture
oscar you know like the guy doesn't know
what he's doing but
the fun thing was that you kind of every
day you go like oh is this going to be
an actor is this frank langella or is
this their you know
guy who repaired their phone last week
you know like it's just like there's no
you know just be friends family and then
real actors too and every day they'd
just be
doing crazy jokes that are you know very
inappropriate jokes on the set and
things like that
um and yet that was their you know they
created like such a fun atmosphere and i
think that's what made that movie fun is
like you know nobody really knew what
was going on most of the time but that's
kind of intentional i think with them
they wanted to keep that energy ben
stiller here on the rich eisen show
let's get to severance what a brilliant
idea this is
um certainly
for our time
yeah it's an interesting you know idea
that dan erickson who wrote the show
came up with
because i think he was working in a
really boring job and he thought one day
what if i could just shut off my brain
when i went to work and not have to
think about this at all and then when i
you know when i left work i'd forget it
even happened and and so he came up with
this idea of a guy who works at a
company where they put a chip in your
brand and you can
basically when you go down the elevator
you forget everything about your life on
the outside and you have your work day
and then when you leave you go up in the
elevator the chip gets activated you
forget everything that happened at work
so you have these two selves an innie
and an audi
and uh and he went from there with it
and um you know adam scott uh who i
adore he is in this as well patricia
arquette who you have worked with before
to tremendous effect
uh in escape at dannemora and then what
christopher walken how did he get
involved what what's that like directing
him ben what's that like yeah well chris
i mean it's actually interesting because
we cast john tuturo uh as one of the you
know the
workmates for j for um for adam at work
but then john's character
has um he meets somebody at work down
there
and a character named bert and
we hadn't cast that person and i was
talking to him about doing the show and
he said well have you cast bird i said
no we haven't said well what do you
think about chris walken
and i was like um i think he's great i'm
a big fan
i don't know if he'd do our show but i
mean he's awesome he's like well can i
ask him and john actually asked walken
if he'd be interested in doing the show
and that's how he got him
no kidding so to tour was like hey if
you cast that guy i got let me get uh
let me just give chris
and it was kind of this dream casting
that i really never thought you know we
actually have in the show but it made a
lot of sense because they have a lot of
stuff together i don't want to you know
get no spoilers but um right he you know
and and working with chris is amazing
he's one of the sweetest
guys uh such a pro like i'm honestly
such a professional he has a lot of
lines in the show
and he would come in every day had his
lines down perfectly just would go do
his thing sit in his chair then go do do
the scene and uh you know really just
and of course everybody's there is going
oh my god we're doing a scene with chris
walken and you know
so he has that he's aware of that that's
around him all the time but he's so
gracious and cool and i actually worked
with him years ago
uh i did a movie with him uh that jack
black and i did that barry levinson
directed years and years ago called envy
yes and then
yeah and then years before that the
first job i ever had as a an actor on
stage around that miami vice time was a
play in new york and chris was in the
play so that was the first time i ever
really met him i was going to ask you
where you go when you think of walking
do you go deer hunter do you go
um pulp fiction easily the one of the
best um uh soliloquies in that film uh
was him with the watch
um or do you go like uh more cowbell
sketch bruce dickinson who you know
makes gold-plated uh records
um by putting his pants on one leg at a
time like which where do you go with
chris walken when you think
what yeah what an amazing career
the breadth of his work you know right i
um
well here's the thing he was actually i
go i mean for me deer hunter is one of
my favorite movies of all time so you
know that that scene the russian
roulette scene is just gonna see my mind
um you know he actually was in a play
with my dad jerry stiller back before i
worked with him um called hurley burley
on broadway that ran for a couple years
i remember seeing that play a number of
times he played a casting director it's
like a bunch of guys in hollywood and um
it was um he was he was so it was
william hurt and chris and chris was so
good in that so that's kind of what i
think of him on stage and you know he's
a dancer too and you think of the fat
boy slim video right um you know i mean
it's incredible he started as a child
actor he's been doing it forever
well severance you can watch uh new
episodes every single friday uh i would
be remiss if i didn't tell you you don't
know joel and evelyn eisen my dad who's
passed my mom was still alive those are
my parents they loved your parents
they never met them but they watched
them and they loved them loved loved
love stiller and mirror loved thanks man
thank you yeah i mean i know you know
they were the best they were the best
and uh it's really nice though because
going through life like i do get so much
feedback from people who allow to say
you know they were a fan or like like
you're saying your parents and they had
a generational
effect uh you know and comedically they
just you know you know they were my
folks when they you know when i was a
kid i never thought about it but now
it's really nice to feel that i don't
know it's the truth man and then you
know obviously
your dad uh with seinfeld and then um
you know because i'm such a a roast
freak i think it was the roast of your
dad where uh jeffrey ross um
slayed b arthur um with a joke once upon
a time it's one of my favorite roast
moments because sarah bernhardt would
did some sort of thing with your dad on
the stage or did you dance for him i
mean that roast was insane
that night ben yeah i mean just to
imagine i haven't watched that since
back back but like you know my dad just
the fact that he even agreed to be
roasted
that was just it's so insane that he
even said yes to that because of knowing
him and how he yeah he was not like a
tough-skinned put-down comic type of guy
you know what i mean that just wasn't he
was like such a sweet person right you
know you'd meet him and he would just he
would just be so positive so you know
just watching him like imagine sandra
bernard doing a dance for him you know
yes it's so not my dad so yeah
oh then and then that bea arthur had no
idea she was about to catch some
shrapnel from jeff ross that was a
pretty something
um before i let you go i i want to give
you the floor on the knicks what do you
think
what do you think about the next right
now
it's not not good right now you know i
think it's not good right now because
it's a mess um
you know
now the season's basically
you know on on the downswing so i don't
think you know i think any like hope of
like the play in is like wouldn't you
know i i don't feel like that's
realistic i don't know if you do or not
um
but you know as a team they're just uh
you know they're i think rudderless i'm
saying generalities here you know
it's just that here was so amazing it's
like been a big big letdown this year
yeah the big mystery is julius randle
you know first of all wearing bernard
king's number is just weird to me but
just but him but him last year being
emblematic of
you know the city and the gritty
comeback and a great story and then this
year you know um you know doing the
thumbs down and stuff it's just been
weird you know it's just been yeah it's
been a little weird with him and uh yeah
i i i think it's a it's a very tough
environment obviously playing in new
york and it's so up and down and it
happens you know very quickly and he had
such an amazing year last year
um that
you know there was so much expectation
and how people react i don't you know i
don't know how you deal with that but
you have to you know figure out some way
to deal with it as a player in new york
i think the fans want to rally around uh
him and the team but it's you know and
you know what like right before the
all-star break he had a run of like five
or six games where he was playing like
he played last year um but the
consistency hasn't been there and you
know who knows i you know how how they
can do it at that level consistently but
the consistency thing for the entire
team has just been like one day you know
and lately it's totally gone away but it
used to be earlier even in the season
that like you know one one day they'd
show up and they were playing great and
then the next day it would be back to
you know unawful games and that's what's
so infuriating for the fans like you
just want to to give us a little
consistency who is your nick growing up
who was your nick growing up who was the
guy well i was around as like an
eight-year-old you know
when like in 73 so i kind of remember
you know that team but you know for me
bernard was bernard king was definitely
my guy and then there was uh you know
mike glenn off the bench yes singer
i remember him big mike glenn fan and i
was always shouting to put glenn in i go
to games with my dad and i'd be shouting
at holdsman put glenn in
um
did he listen did he hear you he did
that every once in a while my and my dad
always like would be like when he was
putting me it's like he listened to me
for a minute he was an amazing shooter
and imagine like mike glenn in today's
three-point game he would have been you
know
pretty uh impactful i remember that mike
glenny was a precursor to trent tucker
right back in the day the old trent
bernard was my guy too ben i i mean one
of my favorite new york athletes of all
time
absolutely loved him
yeah and people i don't know if people
remember but he had an amazing comeback
from an injury you know like where he
literally was out and he came back and
he ended up playing an all-star game and
you know you know a short but great
career in new york could you imagine if
him and ewing actually were healthy
together for a long time like that that
would have been the stuff you know that
would have been the stuff man hey ben
it's been too long it's been too long
with the knicks you know i agree a
really long stretch i agree um thanks
for the call ben really appreciate it
all right um it's been too long
hopefully we'll do this more often
anytime congrats on sex thanks for
having me man congrats on talking about
you you bet congrats on severance it's a
great show everyone should watch it new
episodes uh on apple tv episode four you
can catch on friday first three
are available for you to stream that's
uh ben stiller at red hour ben i follow
him you should too
right here on the rich eisen show that
was uh
dynamite that was awesome
dynamite just loved chatting with him it
was a lot of fun
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here